[Musique]
j'ai encore
des visuels de partir
alors je ne
sais toujours pas pourquoi mais ceux-ci
et je n'oublierai jamais de voir ces
chevaux
et d'être entouré d'un anneau de feu
et je viens de le perdre
et c'est là que j'aime ma force vient
de disparaître et
je dois encore en parler en
thérapie parce que ça me hante ça me hante des
premières
choses que
nous avons faites quand nous avons
déménagé ici, c'est que nous venons d'avoir un thérapeute
et je n'ai jamais réalisé le traumatisme qui
existe toujours à l'intérieur de moi à cause de ce ptsd
et comment il se déclenche et donc juste
le processus émouvant de traverser la ville
euh dans les deux derniers jours juste
déclencher les choses et être honnête avec il y
a eu une cascade de larmes sans vraiment
comprendre pourquoi et se sentir si brisé
à l'intérieur
[Musique]
vous